so you think experts can save us is
there such thing as expertise and
experts in something how do you know if
you've achieved it I think it's it's
important to acknowledge up front that
this there's something paradoxical about
how we relate to to Authority especially
within science
um and I don't think that Paradox is
going away and it's just it doesn't have
to be confusing it's just and it's not
it's not truly a paradox it's just like
there are different moments in time
so
it is true to say
that
within science or within a within
rationality generally I mean just
whenever you're making having a
fact-based discussion about anything
it is true to say that the truth or
falsity of a statement
does not even slightly depend
on the credentials of the person making
the statement right so it doesn't matter
if you're a Nobel Laureate you can be
wrong right the thing you could either
the last sentence you spoke could be
total [__] right
and it's also possible for someone who's
deeply uninformed to be right about
something or in order to be right for
the wrong reasons right or someone just
gets lucky or someone or or and they're
they're middling cases where you have
like a a backyard astronomer who's got
no credentials but he just loves
astronomy and he's got a telescope and
it's he's spends a lot of time looking
at the nice guy
and he discovers a comment that no one
else has seen you know not even
the professional expert astronomers
um
I mean I gotta think that happens less
and less now but but some version of
that keeps happening and it may always
keep happening in every area of
expertise right
um
so
it's true that truth is orthogonal to
the reputational concerns we have among
Apes who are talking about the truth
um but it is also true that most of the
time
real experts are much more reliable than
frauds or people who are not experts
right you know so and expertise really
is a thing right and when it's you know
when you're flying an airplane in a in a
storm
you don't want just randos come into the
cockpit saying listen I've got a new
idea about how to you know how we should
tweak these controls right you want
someone who's a trained pilot and and
that training gave them something right
it gave them a set of competences and
intuitions and they they know what all
those dials and switches do right and I
don't right I shouldn't be flying that
plane
um
and so when things really matter
you know and put in this at 30 000 feet
in a storm sharpens this up
we want real experts to be in charge
right and
we are at 30 000 feet a lot of the time
on a lot of issues right and whether
they're public health issues whether
it's issue whether it's a geopolitical
emergency like Ukraine I mean climate
change
I mean just pick your pick your topic
um
there are real problems
and the clock is rather often ticking
and their Solutions are non-obvious
right and and so expertise is a thing
and deferring to experts much of the
time
makes a lot of sense it's at minimum it
it
prevents
is a spectacular errors of incompetence
and and uh
just uh you know foolhardiness but it
even in in the case of some where you're
talking about someone I mean people like
ourselves who are like we're well
educated we we're not the worst possible
candidates for you know the
dunning-kruger effect when we're going
into a new area where we're not experts
we're fairly alert to the possibility
that we don't you know it's not as
simple as things seem at first and we
don't you know we don't know how our
tools translate to this new area we can
be fairly circumspect but we're also
because we're well educated
we can work and we're pretty quick
studies we can learn a lot of things
pretty fast and we can begin to play a
language game that sounds fairly expert
right and
in that case
the the invitation to do your own
research right is in once when times are
good
I view as an invitation to waste your
time pointlessly right when times are
good now the truth is times are not all
that good right and we have the
the ongoing public display of failures
of expertise we have experts who are
obviously corrupted by bad incentives
we've got experts who you know
perversely won't admit they were wrong
when they in fact you know are
demonstrated to be wrong we've got
institutions that have been captured by
political ideology that's not truth
tracking and this this whole woke
um
uh encroachment into really every place
you know whether it's universities or
science journals or government or I mean
it's just like that is that has been
genuinely deranging
um
so there's a lot going on that where
experts and and the Very concept of
expertise has seemed to discredit itself
but the reality is that there is a
massive difference when anything matters
when there's anything to know about
anything there is a massive difference
most of the time between someone who has
really done the work to understand that
domain and someone who hasn't and
if I get sick or someone close to me
gets sick
you know I I have a PhD in Neuroscience
right so I can read a medical journal
article and understand a lot of it right
and I you know so I'm just fairly
conversant with you know medical
terminology
and I understand his methods and I I'm
alert to the difference because I've you
know because in Neuroscience I've spent
hours and hours in journal clubs you
know diagnosing you know the different
and analyzing the difference between
good and bad studies
and I'm alert to the difference between
good and bad studies and in medical
journals right and I understand that bad
studies can get published and you know
Etc
uh and and experiments can be poorly
designed I'm alert to all of those
things but when I get sick or when
someone close to me gets sick I don't
pretend to be a doctor right I've got no
clinical experience I don't go down the
rabbit hole on Google for days at a
stretch trying to become a doctor much
less a specialist in the domain of
problem that has been visited upon me or
my family right so if someone close to
me gets cancer I don't pretend to be an
oncologist I don't go out and start I
don't start reading you know in journals
of oncology and try to really get up to
speed as an oncologist because it's it's
not it's
one is a one is a bad and potential and
very likely misleading
use of my time right and and it's
if I decide if I had if I had a lot of
Runway if I decided okay it's really
important for me to know everything I
can at this point I want to I know
someone's gonna get cancer
I may not go back to school and become
an oncologist but what I want to do is I
want to know everything I can know about
cancer right so I'm going to take the
next four years and spend most of my
time on cancer okay I could do that
right I still think that's a waste of my
time uh I still think at the end of even
at the end of those four years I'm not
going to be the best person to to form
intuitions about what to do in the face
of the next cancer that that I have to
confront
um
I'm still going to want a better
oncologist than I've become to tell me
what he or she would do if they were in
my shoes or in the shoes of you know a
family member I'm gonna you know I'm
what I'm what I'm not Advocate I'm not
advocating a
a blind trust and Authority like if you
get cancer
and you're talking to one oncologist and
they're recommending some course of
treatment by all means get a second
opinion get a third opinion right but it
matters that those opinions are coming
from real experts and not from you know
Robert Kennedy Jr you know who's telling
you that you know you got it because you
got a you know a vaccine right it's like
it's just it it there's we're swimming
in a sea of misinformation where you've
got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who sh who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no there is no
scenario in which you should be getting
your opinion about vaccine safety or or
climate change or
uh the war in Ukraine or anything else
that we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like like
she she's not a relevant expert on any
of those topics and what's more she
doesn't seem to care right and and she's
living in a culture that has that has
Amplified that not carrying into a
business model an effective business
model right so it's just it's um and
that is something very trumpy and about
all that or like that's that's the pro
the problem is is the culture it's not
these specific individuals
um so so the Paradox here is that
expertise is a real thing
and we defer to it a lot as a as a
labor-saving device as just as and just
based on the the
the the reality that it's very hard to
be a polymath right and specialization
is a thing right and so there are people
who specialize in a very narrow topic
they know more about that topic than the
next guy no matter how smart that that
guy or gal is uh
and and that those differences matter
but it's also true
that when you're talking about facts
sometimes
the the the the best experts are wrong
the scientific consensus is wrong you
get a a sea change in the thinking of a
whole field because one person who's an
outlier for whatever reason decides okay
I'm uh you know I'm gonna prove this
point and they prove it right so
somebody like uh
the Doctor Who uh believed that that
stomach ulcers were not due to stress
but were due to to um H pylori
infections right so he just drank a vial
of H pylori bacteria and and prove that
and quickly got an ulcer and convinced
the field that that at minimum H pylori
was involved in in that process okay so
yes everyone was wrong that doesn't
disprove the reality of expertise it
doesn't disprove the utility of relying
on Experts most of the time especially
in an emergency especially when the
clock is ticking especially when you're
you know you're in this particular
cockpit and you only have one chance to
land this plane right you want the real
pilot uh at the controls but there's
just a few things to say
so one you mentioned this example with
cancer and doing your own research there
there are several things that are
different about
our particular time in history one doing
your own research has become more and
more effective because you can read the
internet made information a lot more
accessible so you can read a lot of
different meta-analyzes you can read
blog posts that
described you exactly the flaws and the
different papers they make up the
meta-analyzes they and you can read a
lot of those blog posts that are
conflicting with each other and you can
take that information in in a short
amount of time you can start to make
um
good faith interpretations for example I
don't know I don't want to overstate
things but
um if you suffer from depression for
example
then there you could go to an expert and
a doctor that prescribes you some
medication
but you could also challenge some of
those ideas and seeing like what are the
different medications what are the
different side effects what are the
different solutions to depression all
that kind of stuff and I think
depression is just a really difficult
problem that's very
um I don't want to Again State incorrect
things but I think it's
um there's a lot of variability of what
depression really means so it being
introspective about the type of
depression you have and the different
possible solutions you have just doing
your own research as a first step before
approaching a doctor or as you have
multiple opinions could be very
beneficial in that case
now that's depression that's something
that's been studied for a very long time
with a new pandemic that's affecting
everybody
it's uh you know with the airplane
equated to like 9 11 or something like
the new emergency just happened and
everybody every expert in the world is
publishing on it and talking about it so
doing your own research there could be
exceptionally effective in asking
questions and then there's a difference
between experts virologists and it's
actually a good question who is exactly
the expert in a pandemic yeah but
there's the actual experts doing the
research and Publishing stuff
and then there's the communicators of
that expertise
and the question is uh
if the communicators are flawed
to to a degree we're doing your own
research is actually the more effective
way to figure out policies and solutions
because you're not competing with
experts you're competing with the
communicators of expertise that could be
who CDC in the case of the pandemic or
politicians or political type of science
figures like Anthony fauci there's a
question there
of
the effectiveness of doing your research
your own research in that context
and the competing
forces there incentives that you've
mentioned is you can be become quite
popular by being contrarian
by saying everybody's lying to you all
the authorities aligned to you all the
institutions aligned to you so those are
the waters you're swimming in but I
think doing your own research in that
kind of context could be quite effective
let me be clear I'm not saying
you shouldn't do any research right I'm
not saying that you shouldn't be
informed about an issue I'm not saying
you shouldn't read articles on on
whatever the topic is and yeah yes if
I got cancer or someone close to me got
cancer I I I probably would read more
about cancer than I've read thus far
about cancer and I've read some
um
so I'm not I'm not making a virtue of
ignorance
and a blind obedience to Authority and I
again I recognize that that authorities
can discredit themselves or they can be
wrong
uh they can be wrong even when they have
when there's no discredit there's just
there's a lot we don't understand about
the the nature of the world
um
but still this this vast Gulf between
truly informed opinion and [__]
exists it always exists and
um and conspiracy thinking is
rather often you know most of the time a
species of [__] but it's not always
wrong right there are real conspiracies
and there there really are
just awful
Corruptions of you know but born of bad
incentives within our you know our
scientific processes within institutions
and again we've mentioned a lot of these
things in passing but like you know what
what woke political ideology did to
Scientific communication during the
pandemic was awful and it was really
corrosive of public trust especially on
the on the right
um for understandable reasons it was
just it was crazy some of the things
that were being said and still is
and these cases are all different so you
take depression but we just don't know
enough about depression for you know
anyone to be that confident about
anything right and there are many
different modalities in which to
interact with it as a problem right so
there's Pharmaceuticals have whatever
promise they have but there's there's
certainly reason to be concerned that
they don't work well for everybody and
and
uh yeah I mean that's it's obvious they
don't work well for everybody but they
do work for some people
um
but again depression is a multifactorial
problem and they're they're different
levels at which to to influence it and
they're you know the things like
meditation they're things like just life
changes and
and uh
you know one of the perverse things
about depression is that when you're
depressed all of the things that would
be good for you to do or precisely
things you don't want to do you don't
have any energy to socialize you don't
want to get things done you don't want
to exercise you don't and
um all of those things if you've got
those up and running they do make you
feel better in you know in the aggregate
but um the reality is that they're you
know there are clinical level
depressions that are so bad that it's
just we just don't have good tools for
them and it's not enough to tell there's
no life change someone's gonna gonna
Embrace that it's going to be an obvious
remedy for that
um
the pan I mean pandemics are are
obviously a complicated problem but I I
would consider it much simpler than
depression in terms of
you know what's on the menu to be this
chosen among the various choices is less
multifactorial the logic by which you
would make those choices yeah so it's
like we have a virus we have a new virus
it's some version of bad you know it's
human transmissible
we're still catching up we're catching
up to every aspect of we don't know how
it spreads we don't know how how
effective masks are at a certain point
we knew it was respiratory but but yeah
and whether it's we had spread by
fomites like all that we were confused
about a lot of things and was still
confused it's been a moving Target this
whole time and it's been changing this
whole time and our responses to it have
been
you know we we ramped up the vaccines as
quickly as we as we could but you know
too quick for some not as not quick
enough for others we could have done
human challenge trials and got them out
more quickly with with better data
um and I think that's something we
should probably look at in the future
because you know that you know to my eye
that would make ethical sense to do to
do challenge trials
um
but
and and so much of my concern about
covid I mean many people are confused
about my concern about covet my concern
about covet has
for much of the time not been narrowly
focused on covet itself how dangerous I
perceive covid to be as a as a illness
um
it has been for the longest time
even more concerned about our ability to
respond to a truly scary pathogen next
time like what I I for you know outside
those initial months you know if give me
the the first six months to be
quite worried about covid and and the
unraveling of society but in a supply of
toilet paper you want to secure a steady
supply of toilet paper but beyond that
initial period
when we had a sense of what we were
dealing with and we had every hope that
the vaccines are actually going to work
and we're getting and we knew we were
getting those vaccines in short order
right beyond that and and we had and and
we knew just how dangerous the illness
was and how dangerous it wasn't
um
for years now I've just been worrying
about this as a failed dress rehearsal
for something much worse right I think
what we proved to ourselves at this
moment in history is that we have built
informational tools that we do not know
how to use to and we have made ourselves
we've basically enrolled all of human
society into a psychological experiment
that is
deranging us and making it
virtually impossible to solve
coordination problems that we absolutely
have to solve next time when things are
worse do you understand who's at fault
for the way this unraveled
the way we didn't seem to have uh
the distrust institutions and the
institution of science that grew like
similarly exponentially or got revealed
to this process who is at fault here
and what's to fix so much blame to go
around but so much of it is not a matter
of
bad people conspiring to do bad things
it's a matter of
uh incompetence and misaligned
incentives and just just ordinary you
know believe there's plain vanilla
dysfunction but my problem was that
people like you people like Brett
Weinstein people like that I look to for
reasonable difficult conversations on
difficult topics
have a little bit lost their mind became
emotional and dogmatic in style of
conversation perhaps not in the depth of
actual ideas but there I you know a
tweet something of that nature and not
about you but just it feels like the
pandemic
made people really more emotional than
before and then Kimball musk responded I
think something I think you probably
would agree with maybe not I think it
was the combo of trump and the pandemic
Trump triggered the far left to be way
more active than they could have been
without him and then the pandemic handed
big government Nanny State Lefty is a
huge platform on a silver platter a
one-two punch and here we are well I
would agree with some of that I'm not
sure how much to read into the nanny
State uh concept but but yet like
basically got people on the far left
really activated yeah and then gave
control to I don't know if you say Nanny
state but just control the government
that one executed poorly has created a
complete distrust in government my fear
is that there was going to be that
complete distrust anyway given the
nature of the information space given
the level of conspiracy thinking given
the gaming of
of the these tools by an anti-vaxx cult
I mean there really is an anti-vaxx cult
that that just ramped up its its energy
during this moment
um but it's a small one it's not to say
that everything every concern about
vaccines is a species of it was born of
misinformation or born of this cult but
there is a cult that is just you know
and you know
and the core of trumpism is a cult I
mean a q Anon is a cult
um and so there's a lot of lying and
there's a lot of confusion
uh
you know there there are
it's almost impossible to exaggerate how
confused some people are and how and how
fully their their lives are organized
around that confusion I mean there are
people who think that the world's being
run by pedophile cannibals and that you
know Tom Hanks and Oprah Winfrey and
Michelle Obama are among those cannibals
I mean like they're
adjacent to the pure crazy there's the
semi-crazy and adjacent to the
semi-crazy there's the grifting
opportunist [__] and
and the the the the the layers of
of bad faith are you know hard to fully
uh diagnose but the problem is
all of this is getting signal boosted by
a a an outrage machine that is
preferentially spreading misinformation
it has a business model that is is
guaranteed that is is preferentially
sharing misinformation okay actually
it's just a small tangent yeah how do
you defend yourself against the claim
that you're a pedophile accountable
it's difficult here's the case I would
make because I don't think you can use
reason I think you have to use empathy
you have to understand but what like
part of it I mean I I find it very
difficult to believe that anyone
believes these things I mean I think
that there's and there's I'm sure
there's some number of people
who are just pretending to believe these
things because it's just again this is
sort of like the fortunification of
everything it's just it's just a there's
a goo it's just Pepe the Frog right like
none of this is what it seems they're
not signaling an alliance with white
supremacy or neo-nazism but they're not
not doing it like they just don't
[__] care it's just cynicism
overflowing its banks right it's just
fun to to wind up the normies right like
look at all the normies who don't
understand that a green frog is just a
green frog even when it isn't just a
green frog right it's like they're just
it's just gumming up everyone's
cognitive bandwidth with [__] right
I get that that's fun if you're a
teenager and you just want to vandalize
our our new sphere but
at a certain point you we have to
recognize that real questions of human
welfare are in play right there's like
they're really there is this their war
is getting fought or not fought and
there's a pandemic raging and
there's medicine to take or not take but
I mean to come back to this issue of
covid
I don't think my I don't think I got so
out of balance around covet I think
people are quite confused about what I
was concerned about I mean like there
was a yes there was a period where
I was crazy because anyone who has taken
it seriously was crazy because they had
no idea what was going on and so it's
like yes I was wiping down packages with
with alcohol wipes right because
people thought it was tremendous
transmissible by touch right that so and
then when we realized that was no longer
the case I stopped doing that but so
there again it was a moving Target and a
lot of things we did in hindsight around
masking and school closures
looked fairly dysfunctional right but
it's unnecessary I think the criticism
that people would
uh would say about your uh talking about
covet and maybe you can correct me but
you were skeptical or you were against
skepticism of the safety and efficacy of
the vaccine
so people who get nervous about
the vaccine but don't fall into the
usual anti-vaxx Camp which I think there
was a significant yeah yeah enough
number oh yeah they're asking they're
getting nervous I mean I especially
after the warn of Afghanistan and rock I
too was nervous about anything where a
lot of money could be made hmm and you
start you just see how the people who
are greedy who come they come to the
surface all of a sudden and a lot of
them that run institutions actually
really good human beings and I know a
lot of them but it's hard to know
how those two combine together when
there's hundreds of billions trillions
of dollars to be made and so that's
skepticism I I guess you this the sense
was that you weren't open enough to the
skepticism I understand that people have
that sense I'll tell you how I thought
about it and think about it one again it
was a moving Target so there was a point
in the timeline where
it was totally rational to expect that
the vaccines
were were both working but both they
were
they were reasonably safe and that and
that covet was reasonably dangerous and
that the trade-off for basically
everyone was it was rational to get
vaccinated given how many given the
level of testing and how many people had
been vaccinated before you given what we
were seeing with covid right
um that that was a forced choice you're
either gonna you're eventually going to
get coveted and the question is do you
want to be vaccinated when you do right
there was a period where that Force
choice where it was just obviously
reasonable to get vaccinated
in especially because there was every
reason to expect that while it wasn't a
perfectly sterilizing vaccine it was
going to knock down transmission a lot
and that matters and so it wasn't just a
personal choice you were actually being
a good citizen when you decided to run
whatever risk you you were going to run
to get vaccinated because there are
people in our society who can't actually
can't get vaccinated I mean I know
people who can't take any vaccines
they're so they're so allergic to I mean
they they in their own person seem to
justify all of the fears of the
anti-vaxx cult I mean it's like they're
the kind of person who Robert Kennedy Jr
can point to and say see vaccines are
will [__] kill you right
because because of the experience it and
they and were still they I know people
who have kids who fit that description
right so
um we should all feel a civic
responsibility to be vaccinated against
egregiously awful and transmit
transmissible diseases for which we have
relatively safe vaccines
to keep those sorts of people safe and
there was a period of time when it was
thought that the vaccine could stop
transmission yes and so again all of
this is it has begun to shift
um I don't think it has shifted as much
as Brett Weinstein thinks it's shifted
but yes there are safety concerns around
the MRNA vaccines
especially for young men right as far as
I know that's the that's the purview of
the of of actual heightened concern
um but also
there's there's now a lot of natural
immunity out there a lot of basically
everyone who was going to get vaccinated
has gotten vaccinated the virus has
evolved to the point in in in this
context where
it seems less uh dangerous you know
again I don't I I I'm going more on on
the Siemens than on on Research that
I've done it at this point but I'm
certainly less worried about getting
covet I've had it once I've been
vaccinated I feel like it's like so you
ask me now how do I feel about getting
the next booster
I don't know that I'm going to get the
next booster right so so I I was
somebody who was waiting in line at four
in the morning you know hoping to get
get a some overflow vaccine when it was
first available and I that was at that
point given what we knew
or given what I thought I knew based on
the best sources I could consult and
based on
you know based on anecdotes that were
too Vivid to ignore you know both data
and and personal experience
um
it was totally rational for me to to
want to get that vaccine as as soon as I
could
and now I think it's totally rational
for me to to do a a different kind of
cost benefit analysis and wonder listen
do I really need to get a booster right
you know like how many of the how many
of these boosters am I going to get for
the rest of my life really and how safe
is the MRNA vaccine for a man of my age
right and do I need to be worried about
myocarditis for you know all of that is
completely rational to talk about now
my concern is that
at every point along the way
I was the wrong person and and Brett
Weinstein was the wrong person and
there's many other people I could add to
this list to have strong opinions about
any of this stuff I just disagree with
that I think
yes in theory I agree 100 but I feel
like experts failed at communicating not
at doing they did I I and I just feel
like you and Brett Weinstein actually
have the tools with the internet given
the engine you have in your brain of
thinking for months at a time deeply
about the problems that face our world
that you actually have the tools to do
pretty good thinking here it's the
problem I have with that but there would
be deference to experts and pseudo
experts behind all of that well the
papers you would stand on the shoulders
of giants but you can surf those
shoulders better than the Giants
themselves but I knew we were going to
disagree about that like I I I saw his
podcast where he brought on these
experts who had many of them had the
right credentials but for a variety of
reasons they didn't pass the smell test
for Me Maybe One larger problem this
goes back to the the problem of of how
we rely on Authority and science is that
you can always find a PhD or an MD
to to Champion any crackpot idea right
you could I mean it is amazing but you
could find phds and MDS who would sit up
there in front of Congress and say that
they thought smoking was not addictive
you know or that it was not harmful to
you know there was no direct link
between smoking and lung cancer you
could always find those people and you
could end so but you know some of the
people Brett found were people who had
obvious tells to my point of view to my
eye I mean and I saw them on some of the
same people were on Rogan's podcast
right and
um
and it's hard because if a person does
have the right credentials and they're
not and they're not saying something
floridally mistaken and we're talking
about something where
it's they're genuine unknowns right like
how how much do we know about the safety
of these vaccines right it's it's at
that point not a whole hell of a lot I
mean we have no long-term data on mRNA
vaccines
but to confidently say that millions of
people are going to die because of these
vaccines and to confidently say that
Ivermectin is a Panacea right Ivermectin
is the thing that prevents covet right
there was no good reason to say either
of those things at that moment and
that's and then and so given that that's
where Brett was
I felt like there was there was just no
there was nothing to debate we were both
the wrong people to get be getting into
the Weeds on this we're both going to
defer to our
chosen experts his experts look like
crackpots to me and
um
or at least the ones who are most
vociferous on those most on those
edgiest points it seemed most and your
experts seem like what is the term Mass
hysteria I forgot that well no but it's
like it's like with you know climate
science I mean this this old uh it's
received as a Canard for for in half of
our society now but the claim that 97 of
climate scientists agree that human
cause climate change is a thing right so
do you go with the 97 most of the time
or do you go with the three percent most
of the time
it's obvious you go with the 97 most of
the time for anything that matters it's
not to say that the three percent are
always wrong again there are things get
overturned and yes
as you say I've spent much more time
worrying about this on my podcast than
I've spent worrying about covid are
institutions have lost Trust
for good reason right and and it's it
it's an open question whether
we can actually get things done with
this level of transparency and and
pseudo-transparency given our
information ecosystems like can we fight
a war
really fight a war that we may have to
fight like the next Nazis can we fight
that war when everyone with an iPhone is
showing just how awful it is that that
little girls get blown up when we drop
our bombs right it's like could we could
we as a society do what we might have to
do
to get actually get necessary things
done when we're living in this this
panopticon of just you know everyone's a
journalist right everyone's a scientist
Everyone's an expert everyone's got
direct contact with the facts or or some
or a semblance of the facts I don't know
I think yes and I think voices like
yours are exceptionally important and I
think there's certain signals you send
in your ability to steal me on the other
side in your empathy essentially
so that's the fight that's the mechanism
by which you resist uh
the dogmatism of these this binary
thinking and then if you become a
trusted person that's able to consider
the other side then people will listen
to you as as the aggregators the
communicator of expertise because the
virologists haven't been able to be good
communicators I still to this day don't
really know
what is the what am I supposed to think
about the
um safety and efficacy of the vaccines
today as it stands today right what are
we supposed to think what are we
supposed to think about testing what are
we supposed to think about the
effectiveness of masks or lockdowns
where's the great communicators on this
topic that consider all the other
conspiracy theories all the other all
the communication that's out there
and actually aggregating it together and
be able to say this is actually what's
most likely the truth and also some of
that has to do with humility
epistemic humility knowing that you
can't really know for sure
just like with depression you can't
really know for sure yeah where is the
I'm not seeing those Communications
being effectively done even still today
well I mean the jury is still out on
some of it and again it's a moving
Target and and some of it I mean it's
complicated some of it's a
self-fulfilling
uh Dynamic where like so like lockdowns
in theory lockdowns a lockdown would
work
if we could only do it but we can't
really do it and there's a lot of people
who won't do it because they're
convinced that it's this is the
totalitarian boot you know on finally on
the neck of the of of of
the good people who um
uh are always having their interests
introduced by the elites right so like
this is if you have enough people who
think the lockdown for any reason in the
face of any conceivable illness right is
just code for the new world order coming
to [__] you over and take your guns
right okay you have a society that is
now immune to reason right because
they're they're absolutely certain
pathogens that we should lock down for
next time right and and and it was
completely rational in the beginning of
this thing to lock down given to attempt
to lockdown we never really locked down
to attempt some semblance of lockdown
just to quote bend the curve to spare
our health care System
given what we were seeing happen in
Italy right like that moment was it was
not hard to navigate at least in in my
view it was obvious at the time in
retrospect my views on that haven't
changed except for the fact that I
recognize maybe it's it's just
impossible given the nature of people's
response to that kind of
Demand right we live in a society that's
just not going to lock down unless the
pandemic is much more deadly right so
that's a point I made which you know was
maliciously clipped out from some other
podcast where someone's trying to make
it look like I want to see children die
look there's a Pity more children didn't
die from covet right
um this is uh it was actually the same
person who who uh and that's the other
thing that got so um
poisoned here it's like that person this
this psychopath or effective psychopath
who's creating these clips of me on
podcasts the second clip of me
uh seeming to say that I wish more
children died during covet which but it
was it was so I was so it was so clear
in context what I was saying that even
the clip betrayed the context so it
didn't actually work this psycho and
again I don't know whether he actually
is a psychopath but he's behaving like
one because of the incentives of Twitter
this is somebody who Brett signal
boosted as a as a very reliable source
of information right he he kept
retweeting this guy at me against me
right and this guy at one glance I knew
how unreliable this guy was right but I
think I
I'm not at all set one thing I think I
did wrong one thing that I do regret one
thing I have not sorted out for myself
is
how to navigate the the
professional and personal pressure
that gets
applied at this moment where you have a
friend or an acquaintance or someone you
know
who's behaving badly in public or or
Behaving Badly behaving in a way that
you think is bad in public
and they have a public platform where
they're influencing a lot of people and
you have your own public platform where
you're constantly getting asked to
comment on what this this friend or or
acquaintance or colleague is doing
I haven't known what I think is
ethically right about the choices that
seem forced on us and at moments like
this so like I've criticized you in
public about your interview with Kanye
now in the case in in that case I
reached out to you in private first and
told you exactly what I thought and then
when I was going to get asked in public
or when I was touching that topic on my
uh podcast I more or less said the same
thing that I said to you in private
right now that was how I navigated that
moment
um I did the same thing with you with
Elon uh at least on at the beginning
um
you know this we have we have maintained
Good Vibes that was just which is not
what I know Elon but I don't think I I
disagree with you because Good Vibes in
the moment there's a deep core of Good
Vibes that persists through time between
you and Elon and I would argue probably
between some of the other folks you
mentioned I I think with Brett I failed
to reach out in private
uh to the degree that I should have and
we never really had a we we had tried to
set up a conversation in private that
that never happened but
um there was some communication but
it would have been much better for me to
have made more of an effort in private
than I did before it's Spilled Out into
public and I would say that's true with
other people as well
what kind of interaction in private do
you think you should have with Brett
because my case would be beforehand and
now still the case I would like in this
part of the criticism
be sent my way maybe it's useful to go
to that direction actually let's go to
that direction because I think I
disagree with your criticism as you
stated publicly but this is something
yeah the thing you could assess me for
is actually the right thing to do with
Brett okay you you said Lex could have
spoken with Kanye in such a way as to
have produced a useful document he
didn't do that because he has a fairly
naive philosophy about the power of love
so let's see if you can maintain that
philosophy in the presence let's go no
it's beautiful he seemed to think that
if he just got through the Minefield to
the end of the conversation where the
two of them still were feeling good
about one another and they can hug it
out that would be by definition a
success so
let me make the case for this Power of
Love philosophy right and first of all I
love you Sam you're still an inspiration
and somebody I deeply admire okay back
at you uh the to me in the case of Kanye
it's not only that you get to the
conversation and have hugs it's that the
display that you're willing to do that
has power so even if it doesn't end in
hugging the actual the turning the other
cheek the act of turning the other cheek
itself communicates both to Kanye later
and to the rest of the world
that we should
have empathy and compassion towards each
other there is power to that that maybe
that is naive but I believe in the power
of that so it's not that I'm trying to
convince Kanye that some of his ideas
are wrong but I'm trying to illustrate
that just the act of listening and truly
trying to understand another human being
that is opens people's minds to actually
questioning their own beliefs more it
takes them out of the dogmatism
de-escalates the kind of uh dogmatism
that I've been seeing so in that sense I
would say the Power of Love is is the is
the philosophy you might apply to Brett
because the right conversation you have
in private is not about Hey listen
you're you know the the experts you're
talking to they seem credentialed but
they're not actually as Kardashians as
they're illustrating they're not
grounding their findings in the actual
meta-analyzes in the papers and so on
like making a strong case like what are
you doing this is going to get a lot of
people in trouble but instead just
saying like being a friend in the
dumbest of ways being like
respectful sending love their way and
just having a conversation outside of
all of this outside like basically so
showing that like
removing the emotional attachment to
this debate even though you are very
emotionally attached because in the case
of covid specifically there is a very
large number of lies at stake
but removing all of that and remembering
that you have a friendship
yeah well so I think these are highly
non-analogous cases right so your
conversation with Kanye
misfired from my point of view for a
very different reason it was it was
it has to do with Kanye I mean so Kanye
I don't know I'd have never met Kanye uh
so obviously I don't know him
um but
I think he's either obviously in the
midst of a mental health crisis
or he's a colossal [__]
or both I mean there's actually those
aren't mutually exclusive so one of
three possibilities he's either mentally
ill he's an [__] or he's a he's
mentally ill and an [__] I think all
three of those possibilities are
possible for the both of us as well no
moment I would argue none of those are
are likely for either of us but
um possible not to say we don't have our
moments but
so so the reason not to talk to Kanye so
you I think you should have had the
conversation you had with him in private
that's great and there's no I've got no
uh criticism
of what you said had it been in private
in Pub I just thought
you're not doing him a favor if he's
mentally ill right
if he's in the middle of a a manic
episode or or you know I'm not a
clinician but I've heard it said of him
that he
is bipolar um you're not doing him a
favor sticking a mic in front of him and
letting him go off on the Jews or
anything else right
um we know what he thought about the
Jews we know that there's not much
illumination going to cut it's going to
come from him on that topic and if it is
a symptom of his mental illness that he
thinks these things well then it's
you're not doing him a favor making that
even more public
um if he's just an [__] and he's just
an anti-semite in an ordinary you know
Garden variety anti-semite well then
there's also not much to say unless
you're really going to dig in and kick
the [__] out of him in public and I'm
saying you can do that with love I mean
that's the other thing here is that
I don't agree that compassion and love
always have this patient
uh embracing acquiescent
face right they don't always feel good
to the recipient right there is a sword
of wisdom that you can wield
compassionately in moments like that
where someone's full of [__] and you
just make it absolutely clear to them
and to your audience that they're full
of [__] and it's no there's no hatred
being communicated in fact you could
just it's like listen I'm going to do
everyone a favor right now and you know
just take your foot out of your mouth
and and
um
and the truth is you know I wouldn't I
just wouldn't have aired the
conversation like I just don't think it
was a document that had to get out there
right I I get that many P this is not a
signal you're likely to get from your
audience right I get that many people in
your audience thought oh my God that's
awesome you're talking to Kanye and
you're doing it in Lex style where it's
just love and you're not treating him
like a pariah and you know you're you're
holding this tension between he's this
creative genius who we lose work we love
and yet he's having this moment that's
so painful and you know what a tightrope
walk and I get that maybe 90 of your
audience saw it that way they're still
wrong and I and I still think that was
non-balanced not a good thing to put out
into the world you don't think it opens
up the mind and heart of people that
listen to that just have it
if it's opening it up in the wrong
Direction Where just gale force nonsense
is coming in right I think we should
have an open mind and an open heart but
there's some clear things here that
that we have to keep in view one is the
mental illness component is its own
thing yeah I don't pretend to understand
what's going on with him so but insofar
as that's the reason he's saying what
he's saying
do not put this guy on camera and let
know but sorry on that point real quick
I had a bunch of conversation with them
offline and I didn't get a sense of
mental illness that's why I chose to sit
down okay and I didn't get it I mean
mental illness is such a
but when it shows up in a [__] put on
Alex Jones's podcast I mean so either
that's more you know genius performance
in his world or it's he's unraveling
further I wouldn't put that under mental
illness I we have to I think there's
another conversation to be had about
how we treat artists
right because they're they're weirdos
they're very I mean we you know taking
taking words from Kanye as if he he's
like Christopher Hitchens or something
like that like very eloquent researched
you know written many books on history
and politics and geopolitics on
psychology Connie didn't do any of that
he's an artist just spawning off and so
there's a different style conversation
and a different way to treat
the words that are coming out let's
leave the mental illness aside so if
we're going to say that there's no
reason to think he's mentally ill and
this is just him being creative and
Brilliant and opinionated
well then that falls into the [__]
bucket for me it's like then then he's
someone and honestly the most offensive
thing about him in that interview from
my point of view is not the
anti-Semitism which you know we can talk
about because I think there there are
problems just letting him uh
uh spread those memes as well but the
most offensive thing is just how
delusionally egocentric he is or was
coming off in that interview and in
others like he he has an estimation of
himself as this Omnibus genius the the
to right not only to rival Shakespeare
to exceed Shakespeare right I mean he's
like he's he's the greatest mind that
has ever walked Among Us and he's more
or less explicit on that point and yet
he manages to talk for hours without
saying anything actually interesting or
insightful or or factually Illuminating
right so it's complete delusion of a
very trumpian sort it's like it's like
you know when Trump says he's a genius
who understands everything but nobody
takes him seriously
and one wonders whether Trump takes
himself seriously Kanye seems to believe
he seems to believe his own press he
actually thinks he's he's you know uh
just a Colossus and
um he may be a great musician you know
I'm not you know I I've certainly not my
wheelhouse to compare him to any other
musicians but
um
one thing that's patently obvious in
from your conversation is he's not who
he thinks he is intellectually or
ethically or in any other relevant way
and so when you couple that to the
anti-Semitism he was spreading which I
what was genuinely noxious and
ill-considered and
um has
potential knock-on effects in the black
community I mean there's there's a
there's an ambient level of
anti-Semitism in the black community
that is worth worrying about and talking
about anyway there's a bunch of guys you
know playing The Knockout game in
Brooklyn just punching Orthodox Jews in
the face
and I think letting Kanye air his
anti-Semitism that publicly only raises
the the likelihood of that rather than
diminishes it I don't know so let me say
just a couple of things so one my belief
at the time
was it doesn't it decreases it showing
empathy while pushing back decreases
likelihood of that it does might it
might on the surface look like it's
increasing it but that's simply because
the anti-Semitism or the hatred in
general is brought to the surface and
then people talk talk about it but I
should also say that you're one of the
only people that wrote to me privately
criticizing me and uh like out of the
people I really respect and admire and
that was really valuable that like I had
to it's painful because I had to think
through it for a while I'm still it
still haunts me because the other kind
of criticism I got a lot of people
basically said
thinks towards me uh
based on who I am that they hate me just
just you mean anti-semitic things or
that you're anti-semitic because I just
hate the word anti-semitic it's a it's
like racist but here's the reality
so I'm someone so I'm Jewish you know
although obviously not religious
um
I have never taken you know I've been a
student of the Holocaust obviously I
know a lot about that and and there's
reason to
to be a student of the Holocaust but
in my lifetime and in my experience I
have never taken anti-Semitism very
seriously I'm not worried about it I
have not made a thing of it I've done
exactly one podcast on it I had Barry
Weiss on my podcast
um when her book came out
but
it really is a thing and it's uh
it's something we have to keep an eye on
societally because it it it's the it's a
unique kind of hatred right it's it's
Unique in that
it seems It's knit together with it's
not just ordinary racism it's knit
together with lots of conspiracy
theories that never seem to die out
um it's it can by turns equally animate
the left and the right politically and
it was so perverse about anti-Semitism
like look in the American context with
the far right you know with white
supremacists Jews aren't considered
white so they hate us and the Same
Spirit in which they hate black people
or brown people or anyone who's not
white
but on the left Jews are considered
extra white I mean we're we're the extra
beneficiaries of white privilege right
and in the black community that is often
the case right we're a minority that has
thrived and so and and it seems to stand
as a Counterpoint to all of the problems
of of other that other minorities suffer
in particular you know African-Americans
in the American context
um and yeah Asians are now getting a
little bit of this you know like the the
model minority uh uh issue but Jews have
had this going on for centuries and and
Millennia and it never seems to go away
and it's again this is something that
I've never focused on but
this has been at a slow boil for as long
as we've been alive and there's no
guarantee it can't suddenly become much
much uglier than we have any reason to
to expect it to become Even in our
society and so
um there's a there's kind of a special
concern at moments like that where you
have an immensely influential person in
a community
who already has a checkered history with
respect to their own beliefs about the
Jews and the conspiracies and all the
rest uh and he's just messaging uh you
know not especially fully opposed by you
and anyone else who's given him the
microphone at that moment
to the world and that so that that
you know made my Spidey Sense yeah it's
complicated it's the stakes are very
high and as somebody that's been
obviously family and also reading a lot
about World War II yeah and just this
whole period is a very difficult
conversation but I I I I believe in the
power especially uh given who I am of
um not always but sometimes often
turning the other cheek
oh yeah and again things change
when when they're for public consumption
you know when you're so it's like I mean
the the cut for me that you know has
just the use case I keep stumbling upon
is the the kinds of things that I will
say on a podcast like this or if I'm
giving a public lecture
versus the kinds of things I will say at
dinner
with strangers or with friends like like
if you're in an Elevate like if I'm in
an elevator with strangers I do not feel
and I hear someone say something stupid
I don't feel a an intellectual
responsibility to turn around in that
you know in the con in the confines of
that space with them and say listen that
thing you just said about X Y or Z is
completely false and here's why right
but if somebody says it in front of me
on some public bias where I'm actually
talking about ideas that's when you know
there's a different responsibility that
comes online the question is how you say
it how you say it or even whether you
say anything in in those I mean there
are moments there there are definitely
moments to privilege civility or just to
pick your battles I mean some sometimes
it's just not worth it to get into it
with somebody out out in in real life I
just believe in the power of empathy
both in the pre in the elevator and when
a bunch of people are listening
that when they see you willing to
consider the another human being's
perspective
I it just gives more power to your
to your words after well yeah but until
it doesn't like if because you can
you can right you can extend charity too
far right you could like it can be
absolutely obvious what someone's
motives really are and they're they're
you know dissembling about that right
and so then you're taking at face value
their representations begins to look
like you're just being duped and you're
not you're not actually doing the work
of of putting pressure on a bad actor
you know so it's it's and again the
whole the mental illness component here
makes makes it very difficult to think
about what you should or shouldn't have
said to Kanye